tigers now get ready to face guy who's
been wow just a big impact on this twins
rotation in his first year with the
twins the 32 year old native of japan
kenta maida swinging a line drives
softly deep at shore back into bipolanco
throws across his body to first no
chance to get victor reyes infield
single for reyes so now candelario one
for his last 18 he swings and towers one
to center field playable
buxton drifting back a few steps to his
left he'll call and catch in front of
his left shoulder for out number three
tigers don't score they leave one casey
still looking for his first big league
win the walks have been a challenge
given up a basically a hit per inning
keep the base runners down and twins
have to keep that split up in the strike
zone oh back up cutter i believe on the
inside part of the plate at 89. i will
go with the cutter right there that was
a called third donald's a note for three
yesterday swings and pops it up
in the shallow left field wow that ball
is going to carry ways but it will be
playable for castro
that ball left his bat like a pop-up
donaldson flies out of one two three
first for casey mize to go to the second
inning scoreless amigo goodrum leads off
the tiger second base is empty nobody
out don't score and the one-two pitch he
got him and down goes goodram not a
change-up and that is career strikeout
number 713 for kenta swag and a miss and
doubt he goes chase to change up so
back-to-back strikeouts for maeda two
down and the one-two pitch swagger to
miss tied him up on a righty-righty
change-up and down goes cameron no
scores into the top of the third inning
9-1-2 hitters paredes reyes-castro and
the one-two and down he goes paredes
strikes out on a change-up so four
strikeouts for miata one down no score
third inning and here is reyes and the
02 and down he goes on a fast ball maeda
has the strikeout pitch and pitches
rolling right now so two outs another
strikeout that's five tonight three-two
pitch a fly ball center field playable
buxton in now over to his right calls
and catches cap eye and that's a one two
three third for maeda the twins have a
base runner lead off knock for polanco
and here is gonzalez
sharply hit into right field of base hit
polanco around third he's coming home
and the twins get the first lead and
it's one-nothing twins buxton will bat
with runners on the corners and nobody
out and the pitch is swinging a ground
ball to the hole at short played by
castro's second for one goodrum's return
no chance
byron's save gonzalez scores out at
second base it's an rbi for byron and
the twins take a two-nothing lead
slow tapper to third on the bare hand
paredes beautiful play to end the inning
he gets donaldson by a couple of steps
but minnesota scores a couple and here's
jake cave cave struck out swinging his
first time up crushed to right field
jk tees off a long home run and it's
four to nothing ends up getting
something he can drive and he did not
miss this ball way back there it is guys
are going to be fighting over that thing
batter of the game got an infield hit
and maida hasn't given up a hit since
swung out and missed and another
strikeout for maeda strikeout number six
for kentucky and a swing and a miss boy
over powered three up three down inning
for kenta maeda with seven strikeouts
mize is going to stay in to see eddie
here in this fifth inning at bat
left center and deep to the bullpen
reyes going back still going back and
that ball's gone rosario with a two run
home run into the bullpen and it's six
to nothing
i love it it's like a prize fighter
after a fight just went deep
reyes
aboard just the second hit against maeda
they've both been lead off single
flare into left field here comes cave on
cave dives and makes the catch a
superman dive and came up caught it
right in front of his face cave out of a
great night well cabrera is up now with
runners at first and second and one down
the 1-0
swinging a line drive left field this
one is deep to left and this one is way
back and gone how about that into the
bullpens in deep left center field that
was a rocket and the tigers have cut it
to six three six seven eight hitters
caved against nick ramirez cave lifts it
to left
castro retreats he's back at the wall
and that ball is gone
cave goes to the opposite field his
second of the ball game fourth of the
year he wants the road back they'll load
it up and the tying run will come to the
plate in victor reyes the one-two pitch
he got him strike three and a high
fastball at 90 first pitch a swing at a
pop-up playable
shallow center polanco out buxton in
polanco calling catching and the tigers
don't score in league three
wonderful job by clipper came in base is
loaded only one out retires reyes and
castro and the tigers
leave the maximum
will come up with two men aboard here's
the 1-1
did he get it to deep left get out of
here yes
a second three-run bomb of the night for
miguel
and it is seven to six
bouncer to the right side cenote juggles
it has to run to the bag to end the game